To see how that is really done, let's
just look at how unique started for
example.
So you provide a User ID and
your password.
We use the User ID to select
the entry in the password file for
this user that we're talking about.
The salt is stored here.
The hash value's stored here, isn't it?
This is sort of the data
structure we keep.
To log in,
you're going to supply your password, so
we start on this side later on.
So this is what is set up initially for
create the user account or
set up the password.
At that time, we determine the salt and
computer hash value and
things like that.
So later on a user comes
types the password.
Well, they're saying who they are.
You give your user id, your log in name.
Based on that, we're going to
find the hash value and the salt.
So the salt and the password are going
to be put through this hash function.
And it's slow because if
somebody's doing brute force,
it pays to slow them down.
So we passed these two things
through the hash function.
So this is typed by the user based on
the claim by the user, who they are.
This is what we find in the file that
we have, where we store the salt value.
So the two are passed as input to this.
The result is compared
with a stored hash value.
If the two match then we allow
authentication is successful.
If they don't match,
then authentication fails.
So this is what happens when we have
makers of salt to deal with different
users making the same password and
the result having the same hash value.
And that would be a problem.
When you add salt, the rainbow based,
rainbow table based attack,
think about what would happen to that.